[Music]
my name is keith ellenbogen i'm a
wildlife photographer and i really
focus mostly on underwater environments
i really enjoyed the challenge here of
looking not only just at big animals but
now to look at these microscopic
planktonic creatures so i went about and
collected some plankton
uh and put them in a bowl and here you
can see a concentrated amount of
plankton
that i sampled and then i took a little
bit of this and photographed it under a
light microscope using darkfield and
what i really enjoyed about this is it's
really the same skills i have a lot of
patience a lot of looking around a lot
of like finding the right animal
and then photography and this is what's
called the novotny um which i looked up
is it's cool little i sort of like them
because they have this cone head kind of
shaped and you can see that uh what is
different a little bit for a microscope
in some ways depth of field which in
photography is always omnipresent but
it's much more present in the microscope
and here one on the top is sort of
translucent and they just floated on the
surface they're really gorgeous and you
can see inside it you can see it's
pregnant with a number of them and they
bloom really fast as i was learning
about them and you can see just they're
stacked run right on top of the other
under a slide within a smallest drop of
water i just i really love the the
feeling of this this image and and the
discovery of this animal um this is a
dinoflagellate it's a photosynthesis so
it takes the sun and makes a lot of the
oxygen we breathe they're really
spectacular they're
very present in the in the waters there
they're the most common one that i that
i saw
um and i liked it because uh in this one
you know it sort of moved a little bit
and i liked a little bit of the motion
that happened and i i stacked the images
i took a couple of these and brought
them together so that uh unlike the
other one that the depth of field was
sort of merged together and i liked
playing with this i really found myself
enjoying uh looking under a microscope
in a way that i've never really done
and this is a larval crab that was kind
of just drifting there you can see his
two eyes and
this was a little bigger um but uh i
think at the largest size you can
photograph under a microscope and really
too small for my for my lens um but i i
very much enjoyed this process and the
discovering an array of different
animals and i was surprised how much
time it took a lot of time just like my
photography it's a whole amount of
looking through each slide was like a
journey of a day of diving it was really
a wonderful experience and then i
decided to try and collaborate with a
friend to go even smaller and this is uh
using a scanning electron microscope
and this is a diatom so you can see this
is uh extremely uh tiny here we're at
like one micrometer um and so it's just
the magnification is twenty thousand
times it's it you know it's it's uh
we're right in there but this is very
different because it's not with the
light and you use
your positioning and the focus is very
different i don't know really how to
explain it other than it's a lot of like
controls and looking on a screen
and very different to
how i do it in in again the same search
for how to find wildlife uh and how to
find the right diatom and not all are
the same some don't line up the right
way and it's all the same problems of
photography uh just at this minute scale
but i very much enjoyed the process of
learning
[Music]
you